for the curry paste and chopped
lemongrass chili fresh ginger garlic and
kaffir lime leaves - a pestle and mortar
next put an aromatic ground cinnamon and
coriander a pinch of salt black pepper
then bash it into a rough paste finally
add olive oil to loosen and your paste
is done now on to the pork neck add a
glug of olive oil to hot pan and brown
the diced meat carefully
making sure each side hits the heat
locking in that flavor remove and in the
same pan cook sliced onions until brown
around the edges add the curry paste and
fried release all the intense flavors
then put the pork back in along with a
coconut milk and stir
next add chicken stock palm sugar more
kaffir lime leaves soy sauce and fish
sauce to taste then simply simmer for an
hour
slow-cooked for succulents spicy super
easy to make and wonderful serve with
fresh mango salsa pork make curry now
this is angel passed a nice thin pasta
takes 304 minutes three fingers one in
front two behind and this part of the
knuckle